hi my name is gates of suji and the
regional chef debar for the standard
hotels in New York and today we're
making drinks with Casa my first
experience with Kosta was a little Lower
East Side bar in 2003 and I was handed a
red grape caipirinha and I was just one
over at once and at that moment for me
passing that on is it's magic we're
going to make a red grape caipirinha
start with about a half a lime some red
grapes and crush them in a glass add
about 1/2 ounce of Demerara sugar syrup
2 ounces of Kasasa crushed ice give that
a quick stir and a red grape hyperemia
Cheers
if everything about Kasasa is the
variety within the category a category
without a without a lot of strict rules
so there's a lot of variation in
production there's no one definable
flavor of cassava many different types
of wood can be used the aging period is
not strictly sets the stone can be made
anywhere in Brazil so terroir is a big
factor in Kinshasa there's just so much
diversity and it really represents the
culture that comes down